did you love Glass Onion and knives out
are you looking for the next modern
murder mystery to get into while you
wait for Benoit blanc's next movie hey
it's Whitney from new rockstars and I
gotta recommend Ryan Johnson's new show
Poker Face starring Natasha Leone in the
same way that Ryan Johnson pays homage
to Agatha Christie's whodunits in his
Knives Out movies poker face is a love
letter to how ketchum's like Colombo not
only is each episode of the series
stacked with talent but they
structurally invert the traditional
mystery solving format we get to see the
murders take place and attention from
the series comes not from the audience
uncovering the murderers but from seeing
how our disheveled detective is able to
stumble upon the clues and solve the
pieces the real mystery however finding
a good friend who will share their
peacock password with you if you guys
check out poker face and you love it as
much as I do let me know in the comments
if you want to see me do a breakdown
about it